about to get real tagline I'm contacting
you because we have a vandal he goes by
the name the turd burglar
American vandal is coming back for
season two on September 14th and here to
talk about it
Tyler Alvarez I'm so excited about
season 2 season 1 I think was the most
binge-watch show of last year and now
we're finally back for season 2 yeah
where do we pick things up so what
happens is we kind of pick up with a
little bit of telling us what happened
last season with how Netflix picked up
Peters documentary and it became this
big success and all this stuff so Peters
started receiving a lot of submissions
and what kind of a crime to take on next
and the one that stuck out to him was
the turd burglar crime
so Chloe Lyman contacts him about this
turd burglar who tainted the school
lemonade at st. Bernardin Catholic High
School causing everybody to poo
uncontrollably and so that's kind of the
case that we solved and this is this
next season and it the stakes are really
high
poop is poop and yeah it's a lot of fun
I honestly couldn't figure out anything
when I was reading it or like all the
twists and the turns like it's it's poop
but it really does go a lot deeper than
that how do you like going on these
press tours for the show when you go on
these like family-friendly news show
just kind of like censor yourself or you
hire interview well think I'm happy you
said poop and the bees because if that
was kind of my cue okay don't say the
whole word yeah it's you know you know
it's a good time the turd burglar it was
a different going back to season one you
know seeing the trailer for this show I
was like this looks hilarious but I
don't know it could go either way
did you know I mean at what point did
you know that this was kind of a
lightning in a bottle
awesome show after I read the first
episode I got the first script and I
read the whole thing and I was hooked
when they explain the concept to me
that's when I know that I want to do it
cuz I almost didn't play Peter because I
was up for another role at the time so
me and my team of trying to decide which
which project we were gonna go with and
they weren't telling us anything about
the show was about the concept nothing
all I had was my audition sites and I
really liked the other part and then I
gotten the call with all the creators
and they explained
and I was like I have to do this and we
were it's been a dream ever since one of
the best things I mean there's so many
great aspects of the show and I think it
kind of nails everything but in addition
to the writing and everything but the
characters from season one were so great
so I think that's what a lot of people
are wondering for season two is who are
we bringing in to kind of counteract are
missing Dillon Maxwell we have a lot of
a lot of different amazing characters
and they all touch upon different things
in high school and representing
different people in high school that
we've yet to see on American Bandol and
I think that's one of the best things
about our shows we really portray high
schoolers so realistically and so
honestly and I think that's what a lot
of people going to like this season what
they also liked last season we do have a
Dillon Maxwell e-type sorry some
completely different people completely
different characters but you know we
have that kind of jokester person jokes
I don't want to reveal it yet okay okay
in season one it's kind of implied who
the person is at the end but nobody
really knows and we all of our theories
Christa Carlisle do they actually tell
you who it was or okay yes I'm sure
oh I knew I knew for sure for sure okay
I know for sure but they just kind of
wanted to keep it like well the thing is
like I'm no better than the school board
if I can Vick someone or make an
assumption about someone based on
circumstantial evidence that's what they
did with Dillon Maxwell they made and
you know a judgement based on his
character and he got convicted for it
and his life would have been ruined and
still was a little ruined that even
after I proved him innocent
right so with Christa Carlisle I'd be
doing the same exact thing if I were to
say indefinitely that it's crystal Carla
what kind of journalist would I be if I
don't have heart I'm sorry I'm gonna
leave P channeling full Peter right now
I have if I have no hard facts what kind
of you know journalist would I be you
have to stick to the facts as a
journalist I really like where Netflix
is going right now and they're kind of
forming like a little bit of a brat pack
within Netflix we don't know assents neo
and and and you and because you were
also an orange is the new black and
they've got Shannon purser do you have
any other projects on Netflix in the
works or possibly in the works possibly
possibly can talk about anything yet
yeah hopefully if you could appear on
any other show and Netflix what would
happen to things okay I love stranger
things so I am obsessed with shiny new
things so definitely show you things
yeah and they're also doing a ton of
rom-coms when did you be interested in
doing around I would I would it's not
necess
something that I'm so set on doing I can
do you know things are a little bit not
saying the run comes on feet but
something that really sends a message
and something a lot different I like
doing things that people haven't seen
before
do you have some kind of dream role like
if it came to you yeah the Joker I mean
that exists but I yeah but there put
anyone out here so you're good I know I
know hopefully hopefully hopefully yeah
I would be obsessed to do that I love
you know dark things like that yeah I
like going to those weird place have you
thought about like what your your take
on the Joker would be I don't know yet I
haven't thought about it yet but you
know it's it's processing my mind and
something it's got to come to me I like
this so yeah I would be you have no idea
I would go so into it yeah I would love
every single piece of it to I know it's
super early but have you heard anything
about like multiple more seasons of
American bands yeah yeah yeah yeah so
hopefully I can't I can't say anything
indefinitely I'd say it all goes well
all goes well then yeah yeah all goes
well then okay it was there so when they
announced that it was an anthology was
there a point where you didn't know
whether or not you were gonna be coming
back oh no I knew was anthology from
when we signed on for the first season
it was always gonna be that okay it was
gonna be Peter and Sam solving a new
crime each season new cast and
everything like that yeah I always it
was gonna be an anthology and that's
kind of also what I liked about it that
we know we stuck so true to the true
crime right genre of you know being an
anthology series like a lot of them are
cool well hey thank you so much for
coming in I cannot wait to watch season
2 it is September 14th on Netflix yeah
okay it's about to get real